les grévistes de la sncf avait décidé de
poursuivre aujourd'hui leur mouvement de
grève après avoir défendu hier leur
système de retraite il voulait faire
pression et cela durera sans doute
jusqu'à lundi sur le nouveau contrat de
plan qui va lier la sncf à l'état
l'entreprise étant très dangereusement
endettée jean yves perrin bernie mairie
qui est pour la continuité de la grève
de 24 heures
l'assemblée générale des contrôleurs
d'austerlitz est unanime
la grève est reconduite jusqu'à lundi
matin et si le mouvement il y a suivi
c'est que les cheminots s'inquiètent à
la fois de la réforme de la sécu qui
menace le régime de retraite et du futur
contrat de plan qui supprimerait des
kilomètres de lignes et les emplois
c'est uniquement de la rentabilité de la
rentabilité et on refuse d'admettre que
la sncf c'est avant tout un service
public et qu'ils jouent un grand rôle
dans l'aménagement du territoire
conséquence de cette grève un trafic
quasi nul sur le réseau banlieue à
montparnasse il ne valait mieux pas raté
son départ
côté grandes lignes un seul train ce
soir par destination mais peu
d'affluence
on est samedi la plupart des piégés sont
des voyageurs débarquant tout juste de
l'avion
quand je suis parti c'était juste le
changement de gouvernement donc je pense
que les choses sont pas améliorées
depuis très longtemps que vous attendez
hier soir on n'arrivait pas à orly pas
de métro pas de bus taxis
surprise fatras les gares parisiennes ne
sont pas les seuls à connaître ces
perturbations à toulouse pas de train
régional seulement deux trains pour
paris et 1 pour bordeaux la grève est
reconduite jusqu'à demain à strasbourg
la direction qui prévoyait d'abord c'est
ce train sur les 120 circulant
normalement n'est pas sûr de tous les
maintenir les cheminots poursuivre leur
grève jusqu'à lundi à lyon pas de train
régional non plus six tgv vers paris et
5 venant de la capitale
une situation qui doit se prolonger
demain toute la journée comme à rennes à
lille à bordeaux à marseille
bref c'est l'ensemble du réseau ferré
français qui tourne au ralenti